all rights Danny what are we looking at
today actually I believe this is the
dell XPS one which is based off of the
bell FX 1 yeah okay uh this was the
all-in-one computer that we love you
last year this is the update to that and
you've been playing with it for a few
weeks Terence yeah what do you what do
you think you know I like it for the
most part I found that a you know the
touch controls and a lot of the things
that you know we enjoyed from the first
XPS one or back the form factors pretty
much the same as well with big screen
sweated like a 24 way four-inch screen
yeah it's got a 24 inch screen which I
believe the last the last model we had
was a 20th screen so it has gotten
larger the exact same keyboard is back
so it incorporates the touchpad as well
as well as a touch-sensitive media
controls so I mean it's it's your
classic all-in-one it's got a TV tuner
it has a large hard drive they upgraded
the processor on it four gigs of ram so
there's the last one which had like two
games it was a few gigs of ram and it
had and we're running with a quad-core
now instead of a bill or 200 kind of
like that so there's actually a lot to
like about it comes with the remote
comes with the wireless keyboard so it's
a nice it's a nice you know all in one I
mean you can kind of do everything the
to some degree okay but none of them
well yeah we were playing with it
earlier we are playing with the the
gaming and that was a little bit choppy
you had it duh you're playing call of
duty 4 yeah okay game yeah absolutely
absolutely no I was shooting people up
in right but it was actually a lot of
lot of chopped like kind of questionable
framerates and that was with like all
the shading on and things like that and
they up the graphics card on it too so
it's a little disappointing because the
last XPS Rihanna had rattles gaming as
well so he I didn't really care for that
it does still have a blu-ray drive so at
least as far as you know moving stone
could I take that blu-ray drive and hook
it up to my HDTV watch blu-rays on my
HDTV actually no you can't that's one of
the setbacks so it doesn't have video
out no it's no no it's an all-in-one in
that you can't really play nice with a
lot of your other components you know
it's got its got i believe for tweeters
in a sub the sounds not bad but it's
from what i can tell the exact same
sound from the first XPS one it's a jack
of all trades but master of men correct
correct correct how much will this 24
inch monitor / computer all-in-one cost
me like thousand you gotten by the top
of line version right now the top of
line version which we have pictured here
runs i would say roughly about 2500 I
believe it's like 2459 but doesn't
matter yeah I know how you love dongles
okay yeah yeah yeah just touch the
dongle touch the tango you like that
it's not gonna buy yet which is actually
yeah so I mean that's everything with
the purpose of the dongle I mean there
are two types of Donegal's in the world
yes the purpose of that dongle is to
expand its video capabilities so you've
got a composite video as well as an
analog audio right dell has this habit
of just throwing in dongles I'm sure
they have a warehouse of dongles
somewhere yes if they want to go into
where hello you don't want to go the
dongle we're serving yes okay Darren so
you spent a pretty good amount of time
we have scared here uh say blue ball
writing a 1 out of 10 well would you
what would you get this guy right here
and probably have to give it a seven out
of 10 I mean it definitely fulfills all
the rules that's supposed to it is a
classic all-in-one you can do you know
TV computing gaming none of them
especially well but it works so seven
attend
bill pariah go back oh all right Brian
enlighten me dude I cannot figure out
how to open up this this oh it's making
noises on is making noises oh you caught
it ok cool so ok so this is the sony
t500 DF gt500 it's correct which is a
very beautiful eloquent alphanumeric
name uh this is Sony's newest point
shooter yes it is uh it's actually not
out yet what makes this so cool
different than other other than the
slightly bit that's impossible to master
there is actually uh it can also shoot
720p video oh that's won't believe it
that's high definition video that is
that and for something that's like an
appointment shoot body like that that's
kind of unprecedented it is if you're
gonna stick hi def vision video in a
camera I actually think this is the size
to do it it um as opposed to an SLR well
you're much more likely to actually be
carrying this thing around with you
right you stick it in your pocket you
whip it out like at a movie theater
indeed right you have a big 3.5 inch
touch screen menu actually so there are
no buttons really on the camera at all
so yeah there's no nothing physical
right everything's accessible from the
menu button and gives you all your sort
of standard options and then also says
on here it says 16 by 9 aspect ratio so
it shoots it true white screen it does
yeah so and one of the handy things
actually is it comes with a dock which
you can plug it into which charges the
camera there's also an HDMI outlet on
that dock so you could feed it directly
into your HDTV oh sweet so I see it's
got a does have a just have any kind of
image stabilization technology on it at
all it does like my hands get kind of
shaky specially work visually all that
crack and then I try to balance it out
with the myth and that doesn't work very
well he's aggravates it but actually it
does it it has quite nice image
stabilization
I was in a bar actually a bar and I had
had a few drinks and my hands were
shaking and images turned out fine so
that's sort of another plus with this
camera okay cool and it's got a Carl
Zeiss lens on there does 5x to whoever
Carl Zeiss is yeah I don't mystery man
miss Reagan I guess is it makes magical
one he's quite some oh yeah toasted ESET
500g 500 out in November probably wait
late october early november despite the
despite the name it sounds like an early
version of a terminator doesn't have a
plasma gun or liquid metal skin right at
all right well this is actually one of
the nicer point-and-shoots I've used in
quite some time it beats out I think
everything else from some of the cannons
the power shots i think i would have to
give this a solid seven it's all seven
yeah okay okay so that's the dset five
hundred seven out of ten they have fifty
dollars maybe 400 maybe 400 we're not
even sure I could sony has not finalized
price of sony unless pricing on this guy
available sometime in november